>>> WE'RE LEARNING TONIGHT THAT
CHINESE FIGHTER JET
INTERCEPTED A U.S.
RECONNAISSANCE AIRCRAFT OVER THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA AND PERFORMED
WHAT AMERICAN MILITARY OFFICIALS
ARE CALLING, AND I'M QUOTING
NOW, AN UNSAFE MANEUVER.
OUR PENTAGON CORRESPONDENT OREN
LIEBERMANN IS WORKING THE STORY
FOR US.
SO OREN, WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS ENCOUNTER?
>> THIS ALL UNFOLDED OVER THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA LAST WEDNESDAY
ON DECEMBER 21st.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO.
YOU SEE A CHINESE J-11 FROM THE
PEOPLE'S LIBERATION ARMY AND YOU
SEE IT FROM THE COCKPIT OF A
U.S. AIRCRAFT, AN RC-135 RIVET
JOINT, WHICH IS A RATHER LARGE
RECONNAISSANCE AIRCRAFT WITH A
CREW OF ABOUT 30 PEOPLE INSIDE.
YOU CAN ALREADY SEE HOW CLOSE
YOU ARE.
THEN YOU SEE THE TWO AIRCRAFT
DRIFTING EVEN CLOSER TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHEN INDO-PACIFIC COMMAND
SAYS THIS WAS AN UNSAFE MANEUVER
BY THAT CHINESE J-11.
THE RC-135 RIVET JOINT, THE U.S.
JET DESCENDED AWAY.
YOU CAN SEE AS THEY GO FARTHER
APART THERE, SO THAT THERE
WASN'T ANY CLOSER INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE TWO OR THE RISK OF A
COLLISION THERE.
AND THAT OF COURSE IS THE GREAT
CONCERN HERE.
THIS ONLY ADDING TO TENSION
BETWEEN BEIJING AND WASHINGTON.
AND THERE'S CERTAINLY ALREADY
ENOUGH OF THAT HERE.
HERE YOU SEE THE TENSION ALSO
AROUND THE SOUTH CHINA SEA.
CHINA INSISTING THAT MOST OF THE
DISPUTED BODY OF WATER IS ITS
SOVEREIGN TERRITORY.
THE U.S. NOT RECOGNIZING THAT
CLAIM, INSISTING IT WILL FLY AND
SAIL WHEREVER INTERNATIONAL LAW
ALLOWS.
WOLF, THERE ARE GENERALLY
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN AIRCRAFT OF
DIFFERENT MILITARIES IN THE AIR
THAT ARE SAFE AND PROFESSIONAL.
A DEFENSE OFFICIAL SAYS THIS WAS
CERTAINLY NOT ONE OF THOSE AND
THEY WILL RAISE IT WITH CHINA'S
MILITARY THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE
CHANNELS.
>> YEAH, VERY WORRISOME INDEED.
OREN, SO WHAT ARE THE CHINESE
SAYING ABOUT THIS INCIDENT?
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN A RESPONSE IN
RESPONSE TO THIS PARTICULAR
INCIDENT FROM CHINA.
BUT WE CAN SEE WHAT THEY WOULD
SAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, ALMOST EXACTLY A
MONTH AGO THERE WAS A U.S. NAVY
SHIP THAT SAILED THROUGH THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA.
AGAIN, FOR THE U.S.
INTERNATIONAL WATERS WHERE IT'S
ALLOWED TO SAIL.
CHINA CALLED THAT AN ILLEGAL
MANEUVER AND SAID IT WAS THE
U.S. THAT WAS DISRUPTING PEACE
AND SECURITY IN THE REGI